C'est un mot que nous utilisons beaucoup
sans toujours penser à sa signification
et comment cela fonctionne dans différents contextes de notre vie.
En fait, il y a des centaines de définitions de la confiance
et la plupart peuvent être réduites à une sorte d'évaluation des risques,
quelles sont les chances que cela se passe bien.
Mais je n'aime pas cette définition de la confiance
car la confiance semble rationnelle et prévisible,
elle ne va pas jusqu'à l'essence humaine
de ce qu'elle nous permet de faire
et comment elle nous permet
de créer des liens avec d'autres gens.
Je définis la confiance un peu différemment.
Je définis la confiance comme étant une relation confiante avec l'inconnu.
Quand vous voyez la confiance ainsi,
cela commence à expliquer pourquoi elle a une capacité unique
nous permettant de gérer l'incertitude,
d'avoir foi en des inconnus,
de continuer à aller de l'avant.
Les êtres humains sont remarquables
pour faire acte de confiance.
La première fois où vous avez mis vos informations bancaires
sur un site internet ?
C'est un acte de confiance.
Je me souviens clairement d'avoir dit à mon père
que je voulais acheter une Peugeot bleu marine d'occasion sur eBay
et il a signalé, avec raison,
que le nom du vendeur était « Sorcier Invisible »
et que ce n'était probablement pas une si bonne idée.
(Rires)
Mon travail, mes recherches se concentrent sur comment la technologie
est en train de transformer le lien social de la société,
la confiance entre les gens,
et c'est un domaine fascinant à étudier
car il y a tant de choses que nous ignorons encore.
Par exemple, les hommes et les femmes font-ils confiance différemment
dans un environnement numérique ?
Notre façon de bâtir la confiance en face-à-face
est-elle traduite en ligne ?
La confiance est-elle transférée ?
Si vous croyez en Tinder pour vous trouver un partenaire,
avez-vous plus de chances de croire que BlaBlaCar vous trouvera un trajet ?
D'après l'étude de centaines de réseaux et de places de marchés,
il y a un modèle courant que les gens suivent,
je l'appelle « l'escalade de la pile de confiance ».
Laissez-moi utiliser BlaBlaCar en exemple pour le rendre vivant.
Au premier niveau,
vous devez avoir confiance en l'idée.
Vous devez croire
que l'idée du covoiturage est sûre et mérite d'être essayée.
Le deuxième niveau est d'avoir confiance en la plateforme,
dans le fait que BlaBlaCar vous aidera si quelque chose se passe mal.
Et le troisième niveau est d'utiliser de petits bouts d'information
pour décider si, oui ou non, la personne est digne de confiance.
La première escalade de la pile de la confiance
nous semble bizarre voire risquée
mais nous arrivons à un point où ces idées semblent totalement normales.
Nos comportements changent,
souvent relativement rapidement.
En d'autres mots, la confiance permet le changement et l'innovation.
Une idée qui m'a intriguée et que j'aimerais que vous considéreriez :
pouvons-nous mieux comprendre
les perturbations et changements majeurs chez lez individus de la société
sous l'angle de la confiance ?
Il s'avère que la confiance n'a évolué
que dans trois grands chapitres au cours de l'histoire de l'humanité :
locale, institutionnelle
et, ce qui commence aujourd'hui, distribuée.
Pendant longtemps, jusqu'au milieu du XIXe siècle,
la confiance était bâtie autour de relations très unies.
Disons que je vis dans un village
avec les cinq premiers rangs de ce public,
nous nous connaissons tous bien,
et disons que je veux emprunter de l'argent.
L'homme qui avait ses yeux grands ouverts me prête de l'argent
et si je ne le rembourse pas,
vous auriez tous des doutes.
J'aurais une mauvaise réputation
et vous refuseriez de faire des affaires avec moi à l'avenir.
La confiance était majoritairement locale et basée sur la reddition des comptes.
Au milieu du XIXe siècle,
la société a traversé un grand nombre de changements.
Les gens ont déménagé dans des villes à forte croissance,
Londres ou San Francisco,
et le banquier local a été remplacé par de grandes sociétés
qui ne nous connaissaient pas personnellement.
Nous avons commencé à placer notre confiance
dans des systèmes d'autorité semblables à des boîtes noires,
des choses comme des contrats légaux, des règlements et des assurances,
et avons moins fait confiance aux autres personnes.
La confiance s'est basée sur l'institution et la commission.
On parle beaucoup du fait que la confiance dans les institutions et les entreprises
a constamment décliné et continue sur cette voie.
Je suis constamment étonnée des majeures brèches dans la confiance :
le piratage du téléphone News Corp,
le scandale des émissions de Volkswagen,
les abus répandus au sein l'église catholique,
le fait qu'un seul banquier insignifiant
soit allé en prison après la grande crise financière
ou, plus récemment, les Panama Papers
qui ont révélé
comment les riches exploitent les régimes d'impôts extraterritoriaux.
Ce qui me surprend vraiment,
c'est pourquoi les dirigeants trouvent cela si compliqué
de s'excuser, je veux dire s'excuser sincèrement,
quand notre confiance est brisée.
Il est facile de conclure que la confiance institutionnelle ne fonctionne pas
car nous en avons marre
de l'incurie des élites malhonnêtes
mais ce qu'il se passe maintenant
est plus profond que l'omniprésent questionnement
sur la taille et la structure des institutions.
Nous commençons à nous rendre compte
que la confiance institutionnelle
n'a pas été conçue pour l'ère numérique.
Les conventions concernant comment la confiance est bâtie,
gérée, perdue et réparée --
dans les marques, les dirigeants et les systèmes --
ont été bouleversées.
C'est excitant
mais c'est aussi effrayant
car cela force nombre d'entre nous à repenser
comment la confiance est bâtie, détruite avec nos clients, nos employés
et même nos proches.
L'autre jour, je parlais au PDG d'une chaîne internationale d'hôtels
et, comme c'est souvent le cas, nous avons évoqué Airbnb.
Il a admis qu'il était perplexe face à leur succès.
Il était perplexe de voir qu'une entreprise
qui dépend de la volonté d'inconnus de se faire confiance
puisse si bien marcher à travers 191 pays.
Je lui ai dit que j'avais une confession,
il m'a regardée bizarrement
et j'ai dit,
-- beaucoup ici doivent faire pareil --
je ne suspends pas toujours mes serviettes
quand je pars d'un hôtel
mais je ne ferai jamais cela en tant que convive d'Airbnb.
Et je ne le ferai jamais en tant que convive Airbnb
car je sais que les convives seront notés par leurs hôtes
et que ces notes vont probablement influencer leur possibilité
de transaction à l'avenir.
C'est une illustration simple
de comment la confiance en ligne changera nos comportements
dans le monde réel,
nous rendant plus responsables,
comme nous ne pouvons pas encore l'imaginer.
Je ne dis pas que nous n'avons pas besoin des hôtels
ou de formes traditionnelles d'autorité.
Mais nous ne pouvons nier
que le passage de la confiance dans la société est en train de changer
et que cela crée un changement important,
nous éloignant du XXe siècle
qui était défini par la confiance institutionnelle,
et nous rapprochant du XXIe siècle
qui sera alimenté par la confiance distribuée.
La confiance n'est plus pyramidale.
Elle est décomposée et inversée.
Elle n'est plus opaque et linéaire.
Une nouvelle recette de confiance émerge,
elle est à nouveau distribuée parmi les gens
et basée sur la reddition de comptes.
Ce changement va s'accélérer
avec l'émergence de la blockchain,
la technologie de registre innovante sur laquelle s'appuie Bitcoin.
Soyons honnêtes,
comprendre comment la blockchain fonctionne
est complexe.
Et l'une des raisons est que cela implique de digérer
des concepts assez complexes
ayant des noms horribles.
Des algorithmes de cryptographie, des fonctions de hachage,
des gens appelés « mineurs » qui vérifient les transactions --
tout cela a été créé par cette mystérieuse personne
ou ces personnes utilisant le nom « Satoshi Nakamoto ».
C'est un énorme acte de confiance n'ayant pas encore eu lieu.
(Applaudissements)
Mais essayons de l'imaginer.
The Economist a décrit avec éloquence la blockchain
comme étant la grande chaîne pour être sûr concernant des choses.
La description la plus simple
est d'imaginer les blocs comme étant des feuilles de calcul
qui sont remplies d'actifs.
Cela pourrait être un titre de propriété,
une action boursière,
un actif créatif comme les droits d'une chanson.
Dès que quelque chose bouge
d'un endroit du registre à un autre endroit,
le transfert d'actif est horodaté
et publiquement enregistré dans la blockchain.
C'est aussi simple que cela.
La vraie implication de la blockchain
est qu'elle supprime le besoin d'une partie tierce,
comme un avocat,
d'un intermédiaire de confiance ou d'un intermédiaire gouvernemental
pour faciliter l'échange.
Si nous revenons à la pile de la confiance,
vous devez toujours avoir confiance en l'idée,
avoir confiance en la plateforme
mais vous n'avez pas à avoir confiance en l'autre personne
au sens traditionnel du terme.
Les implications sont énormes.
De la même façon qu'internet a ouvert les portes
d'une ère d'informations disponibles pour tous,
la blockchain révolutionnera la confiance à l'échelle mondiale.
J'ai intentionnellement attendu la fin pour mentionner Uber
car je reconnais que c'est un exemple litigieux et trop utilisé,
mais c'est une super étude cas pour une nouvelle ère de confiance.
Nous verrons des cas d'abus de la confiance distribuée.
Nous en avons déjà vus et cela peut très mal se passer.
Je ne suis pas surprise de voir les associations de taxis manifester
partout dans le monde
et essayer de faire interdire Uber en prétendant que ce n'est pas sûr.
J'étais à Londres le jour où ces manifestations ont eu lieu
et j'ai remarqué un tweet
de Matt Hancock, qui est le ministre britannique de l'économie.
Il a écrit :
« Qui a des détails
sur l'application #Uber dont tout le monde parle ?
(Rires)
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui, je n'en avais jamais entendu parler. »
Les associations de taxis
ont légitimé la première couche de la pile de la confiance.
Ils ont légitimé l'idée qu'ils essayaient d'éliminer
et les inscriptions ont augmenté de 850% en 24 heures.
C'est une belle illustration
de comment une fois qu'un changement de confiance s'est produit
autour d'un comportement ou d'un secteur entier,
l'histoire est irréversible.
Chaque jour, 5 millions de personnes font un acte de confiance
et utilisent Uber.
En Chine, sur Didi, la plateforme de covoiturage,
11 millions de trajets sont effectués chaque jour.
Ce sont 127 trajets par seconde,
ce qui montre que le phénomène est interculturel.
Ce qui est fascinant est que les conducteurs et les passagers disent
que voir un nom,
la photo, les avis,
les rassurent
et, comme vous l'avez peut-être vécu,
les font se comporter un peu plus gentiment que dans un taxi.
Uber et Didi sont des exemples jeunes mais puissants
de la manière dont la technologie crée de la confiance entre les gens
de façons et des échelles impossibles auparavant.
Aujourd'hui, beaucoup d'entre nous seront à l'aise
pour monter dans une voiture conduite par un inconnu.
Nous rencontrons quelqu'un
car nous avons swipé à droite pour être mis en relation.
Nous partageons nos maisons avec des gens que nous ne connaissons pas.
Ce n'est que le début
car le vrai bouleversement
n'est pas technologique.
C'est le changement créé dans la confiance
et, me concernant, je veux aider les gens à comprendre cette ère de confiance
afin que nous la comprenions bien
et que nous embrassions les opportunités pour reconcevoir des systèmes
qui sont plus transparents, inclusifs et responsables.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.